and
there's another
pretty significant and very interesting
by the way lawsuit
that also was revealed last week this
lawsuit came from michael cohen
donald trump's former lawyer who
recently completed his three-year prison
sentence
and this one to me is absolutely
fascinating here and if you're not
familiar with it i know david has
actually interviewed uh interviewed
excuse me that was weird michael cohen
um i think a couple times and i think
he's going on michael cohen's show
but anyway if you're not familiar with
michael cohen's imprisonment
very weird situation right he's in
prison for a year covet hits
and of course trying to prevent the
spread of covet in our prisons they say
okay we can send michael cohen to house
arrest right he's not not a violent guy
clearly not a threat of repeat offenses
here so we can send him home
and he can finish out his sentence there
and they did that
then a couple weeks later they said oh
you know what
send him back to jail but you know don't
just send him back to jail
put him in solitary confinement for a
couple weeks
during which time michael cohen says he
experienced severe health problems
including anxiety
and then finally
after all of this happens a judge comes
out sends michael cohen back home
because as the judge said well here it
is prosecutors insisted probation
officers had been unaware of the
forthcoming book when they wrote a
provision severely restricting cohen's
public communications but a federal
judge ordered him return to home
confinement saying cohen's return to
otisville had been quote
retaliatory
and that is exactly what michael cohen
is alleging in the lawsuit he has filed
which was announced last week against
donald trump alleging
that because michael cohen when he was
released from jail to home confinement
the first time
he had been speaking out
you know talking to the press he'd been
doing interviews and he had a book
coming out a tell-all
book and he's alleging in this lawsuit
that trump was angry about this and
therefore
the administration pulled some strings
sent him back to jail
and even the judge who looked at this
again because these circumstances were
beyond bizarre
said
this was retaliatory
so when again much like the dominion
suit against fox when the judge is
already saying
yeah i mean it really looks like x
michael cohen says you know what then
i'm gonna sue for x
we're gonna do this we're gonna find out
exactly what happened
and i support this lawsuit i would like
to see this again
michael cohen's paid his debt to society
he was sentenced to three years
served as three years
and then that weird little thing in the
middle that made no sense
because they said no you cannot talk to
the press you can't talk to the media
you can't do any of this
uh that's
that's bizarre
it's even more bizarre to throw him back
in prison for it put him in solitary
confinement
for 16 days
uh-uh something is absolutely fishy here
and i'm glad cohen has filed this
lawsuit
because
not only does he deserve answers for
this
but the public does
this could be a potential abuse of power
obviously coming from the trump
administration so this lawsuit would
serve not just to
help michael cohen
but also to help the public itself to
find out what the heck happened with
these truly beyond bizarre circumstances
of his re-imprisonment
during a time when the nation was trying
to get as many people out of prison as
possible
to help slow the spread of covid
we've still got a lot more stories to
cover i am farron cousins you can find
me on twitter facebook and instagram at
farron balanced you can also get me on
youtube at youtube.com fair and balanced
youtube.com slash the ring of fire we'll
be right back with more on the david
pakman show
the only streaming service that
specializes in documentaries is
curiosity stream and you can get
curiosity stream one of our sponsors for
just 15 bucks a year when you use my
link below this will give you access to
the world's best selection of
documentary films there's always
so many that you can't get on netflix
hulu or amazon
i just finished watching a tremendous
film the ceo of sinaloa sinaloa a region
of mexico it's about el chapo
fascinating fascinating curiosity stream
is a must-have
if you love documentaries they always
have the best and newest titles they're
always adding new things to the library
and you can watch on all of your devices
they've got documentaries on every topic
you can imagine curiosity stream is
giving my audience 25 office
subscription making it just 15 bucks a
month go to curiositystream.com
pacman the link is down below